what was that uh attitudes of people in
the west to multi-partner relationships
yeah so that's a pre-print that I've got
out now uh it's a funny story I'll be
presenting that at hbest by the way
because you and me both there we go so
I'm on this uh consensual non-monogamy
uh panel which is is really interesting
because it's because I didn't set out
for this study to be a consensual
non-monogamy study and then it's it's
under review with archives at the moment
and it came back with three reviews all
saying we we love the methods we love
the results but we want you to
completely rewrite the introduction from
a consensual non-monogamy lens so I was
like right interesting let's crack on
with that so I pulled in Justin mcgilski
and he's um gonna help me with that
um anyway so this study was
we live in in the UK and in the UK
you're not allowed to do polygamy of any
kind so you're not allowed uh to marry a
man can't marry several wives a woman
can't marry several men it's called
bigamy it's still punishable by seven
years in in prison by the way
um so it's something that's socially
sanctioned and whereas you can you can
have relationships like that they're
generally frowned upon right which is
really really interesting because you
know the if you look at fossil evidence
in your local art biology It All Points
towards at least
active polygyny in in humans in some way
so men having
um a smaller number of men having uh
access to to more women rather than
everything being a monogamous pairing
and also if you look at all
hunter-gatherer societies
um I think something like 86 percent of
hunter-gatherer societies permit
polygyny not everyone tends to be the
chief and you know people who are very
high status in those societies
um but they're permitted in most
cultures that uh a current or uh that
we've previously known about that have
fallen apart so if there's an argument
to be made that maybe polygyny is
something that's hung around as part of
the human mating experience for some
time so we've run a study just basically
to see well do you actually find a
desire for polygyny
in a population I.E the UK where it's
actually
you know this sanctions against it
um because if you can still find
interest in that mating arrangement in a
society where you know people aren't
talking about it you're not allowed to
do it or maybe that's telling you that
we've we've got an a part of our uh
evolved meeting psychology is uh is
still there kind of in the in the
background so that's what we did we
basically asked a a well two studies
actually a large sample of men and women
about their poligenous interest and
polyandry which is the multiple men to
women
and what happened
interesting stuff really interesting
stuff so
um I forgot I've got the exact figures
here because I haven't committed them to
Memory yet so we did quite a few things
in terms of like correlational profiles
and comparing
um interest for polygenous relationships
against for example just having an
effect Fair partners and stuff but
basically what you find is a third of
guys say that they would be open to a
poligenous relationship so a third of
guys say yes I would like to have two
long-term Partners at the same time who
know about each other accept each other
they don't get to have sex with anyone
else just me
and a third of them are like yes I would
be open to that
women being part of that relationship
not so much about one in 20 were saying
yes I would be like a co- girlfriend or
a co-wife
um and then quite a bit of a proportion
that's unsure so about 20 20 of guys are
unsure 14 of women are unsure so
sometimes it's easier just to look at
the nose so 50 of guys are like
definitely no 80 of women alike
definitely no are you surprised at 50 of
men saying definitely no given male
desire for sexual variety
um I'm not surprised because of
when you start looking into polygyny
just how difficult that is to juggle as
a relationship but also remember this is
in a background where people are brought
up to be told that this is wrong
so it's actually more the the other way
around I'm surprised that you've got 50
of men who are saying either yes or or
uncertain
um but what's really interesting is that
you get that big sex difference in
polygyny so women are like no no no no
no
um guys are like yeah okay I'd be open
for it but when you look at polyandry
the Sexes respond pretty much the same
which is that about 10 percent of people
say yes
um about 10 to 20 of people say that are
unsure but most people are saying no and
there's not a big sex difference between
men and women there so the the
um there's a much more drive on the the
guy's side towards uh polygeny then
women towards polyandry but it's about
the same number of men that would accept
being part of a female's Harem as women
who would want to hire him of men around
about 10 percent that's a so much better
way of putting it I should have had you
on the paper summarizing stuff for me as
as you may be aware I'm actually giving
a short 15-minute presentation at H best
this year so really I should go to that
yeah yeah I can get you an invite bro
you speak to me I'll probably be able to
sort you out
um
so interesting stuff there around
stated and revealed preferences
uh oh absolutely absolutely because I
actually I I put that in the paper right
so there's a massive difference between
like would would guys actually like once
you've got the decision there's there's
that whole whole hot and cold reasoning
element to it as well right
um sorry I interrupted not just that was
it it was just the stated and reveal
preferences thing I mean you know guys I
imagine that
uh actually do I I was thinking about
the fact that if a man was offered the
the multiple women in front of him that
it would it would sound great but I
think that that really works best for
short-term mating I think when you
actually are faced with the
Stark thermodynamics of trying to
have a household with two women who as
much as they say that they get on grade
and maybe in the bedroom they're
fantastic I mean we've had a lot of
history of intra-sexual competition
between women
poisoning each other's kids poisoning
each other trying to push them down
Cliffs you know all manner of
that's gone on and it wouldn't surprise
me if
men
may be mediated by status
yeah oh absolutely and when we
um when you look at the data in more
traditional societies you basically find
that women are drawn towards polygyny
only when the benefits they can get out
of the polygenous marriage exceed what
they could get out of a monogamous
marriage so if I've got a husband who
can only invest five
um
all in me or there's another husband
here who can invest 20 in me and another
person well then I'm getting 10 of the
20 which is more than the five so
there's a there's a balance there of
would I be would I be better off on my
own or part of part of this thing in in
terms of having my utilitarian
calculation in that regard yeah it is
and it's also uh I mean a lot of these
societies tend to have a lot of control
over women as well so it's it's like the
the way that women actually uh you know
if they have less the way that they do
things and gain access to things is a
lot of the time through men
um which is a shame what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]